Palestinians are continuing to show fury
over the moving of the US Embassy to
Jerusalem and the support of that move
by other nations
this comes as Israel faces international
pressure over its use of deadly force to
defend its border with Gaza of course
Rana Conor Powell has the latest tonight
from Jerusalem welcome Allah is real
celebrated the opening of another
foreign embassy in Jerusalem today
following in America's footsteps
Guatemala became the second country to
move its embassy to the holy city but
the fallout from president Trump's
controversial decision continues
hospitals in gaza remain in a state of
crisis after israeli troops killed 60
palestinians and injured more than 2,700
people during violent clashes along
israel's security fence on monday for
two months now dozens have demanded
Israel's blockade around Gaza be lifted
Palestinians be allowed to return to
their ancestral homes Israel's response
to the weekly demonstrations and its
policy of using live ammunition on both
violent and nonviolent protesters is
drawing international condemnation
lethal force may only be used as a
measure of last not first resort an
attempt to approach or crossing or
damaging the Greenline friends do not
amount to a threat of series that to
life or serious injury and are not
sufficient grounds for the use of live
ammunition among the casualties were
children and journalists Israel however
says many of those killed were Hamas
militants and their efforts to breach
the fence was a security risk at the
United Nations US ambassador nikki Haley
came to Israel's defense Tuesday I asked
my colleagues here in the Security
Council who among us would accept this
type of activity on your border
afterwards Haley then walked out of the
meeting when the Palestinian envoy began
speaking there were some signs tonight
that their efforts to lower the tensions
in Gaza but we understand just in the
last few minutes that Israel has
launched a series of strikes on Hamas
targets in the
strip Brett cutter pal in Jerusalem
Connor thank you